stop don't order the M2 Ultra Max studio
or especially Mac Pro just yet because
the performance numbers have just leaked
and honestly you might be better off
buying the M1 Ultra version which you
can get for as low as 3 300 on Amazon
and before I get into the league scores
and explain why I want to mention that
Apple made it seem like the Mac Studio
is blazing fast destroying the old M1
Ultra model in so many tasks but it's
actually not that big of a difference at
least in terms of CPU performance so
check out these League scores as you can
see it's pushing
1956 single core points and 27
945 for multi-core and yes this is legit
we know that because this is an official
geekbench listing showing the model
number MAC 1414 which was precisely one
of the Macs leaked within beta code a
while back so it is legit we can also
see it's got 192 gigs of unified memory
and the cores ran at a maximum of 3.68
gigahertz which matches what we saw with
the M2 Max ship within the 16 inch
MacBook Pro but back to the scores that
single core matches right up with the M2
Max's single core score now while almost
28 000 multi-core points sounds like a
huge number and a big Improvement it's
actually not that much because if we do
the math it's only 18 faster than the M1
Ultra scored in geekbench 5. and now on
top of that what you might not realize
is that this 18 Improvement actually
includes the addition of four extra
efficiency cores yes the M2 Ultra has a
24 core CPU compared to 20 on the M1
Ultra and yes I am actually able to
calculate the performance difference if
those extra four cores weren't actually
there so here's how I did it in previous
calculations I discovered that each
efficiency core within the M2 Chip adds
an extra 305 points to geekbench 5's
multi-core score and yes the M2 Pro Max
and Ultra chips all use the same
efficiency cores directly from the M2 so
with four extra ecors on the M2 Ultra
that equals a thousand two hundred and
twenty points so if we take that from
the total score of 27945 that brings us
down to
26725 making the M2 Ultra just 13 faster
than the M1 Ultra if you don't account
for the extra for e-chorus so in reality
the M2 Ultra is gaining only 13 from the
core and other improvements alone but
guess what the M1 Ultra ran at 3.0
gigahertz multi-core while firing all of
the cores at once which is the same as
the M1 Max while we expect the M2 Ultra
to run at 3.4 gigahertz basically the
same as the M2 Max currently does and
3.4 gigahertz is around 13 faster than 3
0.0 so believe it or not the M2 Ultra
chips performance advantages come down
to basically a very simple 13 overclock
of the performance cores as well as the
addition of four more efficiency cores
that's it but all in all if you're doing
cpu-based tasks the raw performance
difference is only 18 faster so if
that's not a big deal to you why not
just buy the 3300 M1 Ultra Max studio on
Amazon using the link below and spend
the extra 700 savings on something else
like a new iPad or some mac accessories
however I want to point out something
very eye-opening about the M2 ultra's
performance in geekbench 6. but before
that I've got to show off our partner
four movies Ultra short third projector
which I believe is the best consumer
projector you can buy winning the top
pick of 2022 award due to its fully
loaded specs like Dolby vision and Atmos
support and 4K alpd 4.0 RGB plus laser
quality with 2800 ANSI lumens of
brightness which is so bright you can
watch during the daytime with the blinds
open and it can project up to a 150 inch
screen with it being just a foot and a
half from the wall offering the best
Plug and Play theater experience you can
get running Android TV 11 so check it
out using the link below now back to the
M1 Ultra if we take that same 18
Improvement and apply it to how the M1
Ultra performed in geekbench 6 we're
left with a score of 20
710 which yes is actually lower than
geekbench 5's scores why well because
geekbench 6 is much more realistic than
the older version because instead of
duplicating the test for each core
version 6 now creates one huge task that
all of the cores have to work on
together which is obviously much more
realistic to what you'd get for a real
world CPU performance and the problem
with the altered ships is that they
suffer from diminishing returns because
they have so many cores working at once
and since the M2 Ultra has an extra four
cores compared to the M1 Ultra it'll
likely suffer even more but even without
accounting for that the big point I want
to make is that in the more realistic
geekbench 6 the M2 Ultra will only be
around 44 faster than the M2 Max MacBook
Pro nowhere near the doubling and
performance that many people think will
happen with the ultra chip even though
it has double the cores that's
diminishing returns for you so in that
case some people might even decide to
just save their cash and buy an M2 Max
MacBook Pro instead or even the new M2
Max Max studio which is absolutely a
great deal now on the other hand we also
have the graphic side of the equation
with new leaks and it actually does look
a lot more promising so if you're more
interested in graphics than CPU
workloads it might actually be worth
spending the full four thousand dollars
on a new M2 Ultra model instead of
saving that 700 bucks leaked benchmarks
just dropped for the M2 ultra's GPU
specifically gfx benches Aztec Ruins
High tier off-screen 4K test as you can
see it now gets 314.8 FPS in this test
compared to 200.9 FPS on the M1 Ultra
making it
56.7 faster which is a massive
Improvement that right there is telling
me it's definitely worth getting the M2
Ultra if you care about graphics
performance because this test uses a
gaming workload which is actually very
realistic now on top of that we could
also look at Apple's own performance
charts and see that the M2 Ultra has a
huge lead over the M1 Ultra in terms of
3D rendering which hints at Apple
potentially fixing the GPU scaling
issues that cause the M1 Ultra to have
really disappointing graphics
performance in some tests on top of that
Apple showed off this chart of video
transcoding performance showing that the
M2 Ultra is significantly faster than
both M1 Ultra and M1 Max which oddly
have the same performance which makes it
seem like apple has finally fixed the
encoder problem with the new M2 Ultra
chip and it's almost twice as fast which
is a massive deal for anybody working
with video so basically the point is
that if you're looking on the graphics
side it looks like buying the M2
ultramax studio is definitely worth it
but hopefully this video was interesting
and useful for you and if it was comment
down below with your thoughts and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you